so i'm curious if you guys have an
opinion on what is
if or even if there is the right way to
approach telling the story of someone
who's still alive playing a character
that's still around do you try and do
your best to
interpret who they are based on what you
know or you know what's the balance
between that and just going with what is
in the story and creating something out
of the page
in my case because i got to zoom with
phyllis who is an unbelievable human um
and she was in really gracious and open
um
that was certainly uh was certainly so
helpful and such a such a gift
but i i think that this is definitely
the
you know the i guess the bible one would
say is the script that georgia wrote so
it's not like i'm playing exactly that
person i'm playing what was interpreted
you know inspired by the podcast written
by georgia so i'm writing the i'm
playing the bird that georgia wrote
in the script
that being said i hope i captured the
essence of the amazing actual phyllis
who i adore
um but yeah that was it's more like
playing i think the
the um
what's been written
yeah and my character wasn't mentioned
as much in the podcast and so it was
sort of just totally going off george's
script and trying to kind of
yeah there's trepidation and you know
you're playing someone else with
hopefully with respect and but also kind
of honoring the story that george is
telling which and she's such a fantastic
writer
what was the most striking thing about
this story to you i think everyone's
going to take a lot of things away from
you know listening to the podcast but
also watching this show they'll take a
lot of things away from it and they
might apply to their life let me think
about relationships that they've had as
well but when you first heard the story
what's this thing that stuck out to you
that was like
i can't believe this
i mean for me it was the length of time
that this therapist had kind of taken
advantage of a patient it was not a few
years it was over 30 years which the
kind of the show pans that whole entire
scope of just like wow
how you would have to
how much work it would almost take to to
do that to someone and i think but also
there's greatness in this in the script
at least of like how it all happened and
but i was shocked by that when i
listened to the podcast yeah that he was
literally living in his guest
house
i mean for me it's funny because i was
going to say how fast
it took
for
that influence to take over like
and then it lasted that long but just
how fast
one could be swayed by somebody i can't
explain that
i know
that for myself and this will happen to
me as well soon i'm sure
i'm working yeah
what was it like working with paul and
and will
creating this thing from the ground up i
know that when
people see the cast list they see your
names and they see their names a lot of
times the reaction would be like this is
just going to be hilarious but it is so
much more than that what was it like
building this whole thing with them
they're so good and they're dropping
into something so deep in this and and
so to be witness to i mean you know i
think like to be witness to them
on this whole other level
was
was such a gift and you know i played
with them at the beginning of my career
like i had small parts in the big
comedies and
and then to see them at like at this
stage now
dropping into something so real was like
a real
gift to witness
um for all of us like casey too like
just just because i to see the work that
she's done in this which is like so deep
and and layered and it's like a real um
i just i love
just love the acting in it so much
do you feel like um
ike dr ike
thinks that he did anything harmful
that's such an interesting question i
think we all
inherently like to think that we haven't
done certain things so i think
that's wrestled with in the script of
comment how much did he intend to do but
then of course there's certain points
where it's like okay you know in our own
lives we know when we're doing something
wrong
and so
yeah i think it's i think you have to
kind of see for yourself and judge what
you think he knew and what he didn't and
also there's accountability on marty's
part too yeah like you know we kept
saying it takes two to tango like
you know it's like uh there's like that
awesome ethical kind of like interesting
area that's just like who
you know who
marty didn't have to go along with
anything
so it's just an interesting you know
it's just it just continues to be this
interesting like
whirlpool of decisions that all of a
sudden it's out of his control but is it
so it's interesting
yeah and i i do think that the show will
offer up a lot of conversation for
people thank you so much you too thank
you
you